yeah yeah you're gonna feast on this one conceptuality is something other than itself
there's been a change in the image of thought that's what it is, that's what it is, that's what
it is, the internal structure of. But as soon as an utterance slips from the mouth, it's divorced
from the subject. John, what do you do? Are you are you are you dipping that, uh, no nicotine stuff?
so i'll be honest with you i've started to slide back like i know it's so i know i know so i'm like
i'm combining and like every other one like and and i need to i need to get back off of that because
it's like i i literally had totally quit had totally quit and then i started kind of just
bought one i started inching yeah i started inching back well i in the way that i've always been like
where i quit smoking quit drinking i always have some i have to have it there like and not and
actively choose not to use it right like it can't be that it's not there because then i'll just go to
the store you know so for whatever reason and and then i just was like well let me just try this and
see what it does it's like oh this actually feels kind of nice and then and then and it was over the
course of like three months you know in fact this last three months that i've slowly gone to and now
it's like 90 back and 10 only 10 fake oh god well so you're just back on it yeah you just i uh
i thought i was gonna slide back into it because when i hang out with my friends they all have the
they all have cans of shit yeah they all have the the views cigarettes whatever it is yeah um and so
when i'm with them i'll do it but then i've i've committed to not buying it myself so it's i've only
done it like once or twice over like five months yeah so so i'm better than you is what i'm saying
you're winning you're winning man i am not i am not winning i am not winning that's all right
that's all right you'll i mean i think the trick is uh not buying it that would be my advice
it's to not have it around yeah if i if i don't have it around because every time i've quit something
i have it around and it's and and so what that means i guess is that i'm constantly deciding not
to have a cigarette i'm constantly deciding and so i feel a sense of accomplishment all of the time
whereas if it's not there i'm never deciding that and i'm always like you know it always feels like
let me just go get some and then i won't have it whatever i guess whatever you know what i guess i
kind of have a version of that because there are still cans of zins like in my car somewhere is that
right you know what i mean like so if i really wanted one i really wanted you could go get it right
i mean that's how and i think i'm gonna i think i'm gonna do the quitting drinking thing again
which i was so good at and so you guys came and visited me at the at the beach and like
fucked it all up man because we because because booboo had to try scotch for the first time
and i'm like wow i mean this is an occasion in a man's life right like
that's what set you back yeah that was like a year and a half was that like two years ago now
yeah that's what yeah it was a year and a half ago that's what that's what because i
because i had quit drinking for like three years and oh my god that was the that that's what that's
what put me back on the wagon or off the wagon i don't remember which one it is jesus
all right cool well uh do you want to do your nathaniel you want to do your job
uh yeah sure intro the podcast please hey everyone welcome back to Thinking With a rhetorical theory
podcast we're on our 10th episode of uh Nietzsche's Gay Science and we're in book four doing our second
go around on book four last time i think we opened up just talking about this is John's favorite
i think it's your favorite part of your favorite book of your favorite author right
so we're sort of like really i'm gonna try to not say anything today yeah right
yeah i think there was uh
there's a lot of unhappiness in the section that yeah that i was reading
you know it reminds you know what struck me reading it i mean again
this is just a thought that popped in my head a couple of times as i was going through it and yes
i've read this many many many many times it it just reads so much like the stoics it reads so much like
marcus Aurelius or you know there's just so much of that like how to live yeah you know how how to live
well kind of advice recommendations you know or and it just it just sounded to me so much more like
the stoics that i'd ever really been aware of before
you know the stoic thing is interesting for a couple of reasons for what i mean it definitely
yeah, feels like that. And the advice is just, I think, so nuanced and
yeah, it's like, um, this is not Jordan Peterson telling you to get up and make your bed.
Although 308, the history of every day, what is the history of your every day? Consider the habits of
which it consists. Are they the product of innumerable little cowardnesses and lazinesses, or
your courage and and innovative reason? And that's like, oh man, that does kind of sound like that, but
then, yeah, the move, then of course it moves different as the two cases may be. People could conceivably
give you equal praise, and you might actually benefit them equally either way. However, praise and benefit and
respectability may be enough for those who merely want a good conscience, but not for you who scrupulously
examine the inside of things and know about conscience.
It looks, it looks, it looks like sort of straightforward advice, um, and that I think that's a good way, or at least how I think of it. It reads
like the Stoics. It reads like advice on how to live, and then it takes, it often will take a turn that you realize it's a
diagnosis of ways of living. It's not advice. It's not saying make your bed. It's just saying like here are different ways of
of living in the world. Here's the kind of life of making your bed, and sometimes you do need to make your bed, and you know what other
times you need to let that shit stay unmade. So how would you, how would you characterize the difference then between
Nietzsche's approach and and the Stoic approach because it seems like
both are invested in
discomfort at some level but like you're just saying that Daniel
maybe the Stoic approach is like it's too committed
or too one directional like maybe
niches invested in some sort of sensitivity
First off, I feel motivated when I read it.
I I I like reading it. I do feel
motivated, but to like yeah turn it into
like the to turn it into simply that
you just have to
subtract, you know, a sell like 15 to
20 percent of nuance from it and you said
like not pay attention to a few of the buts
or the those or the turns or whatever
which which is everything that forces you to like, you know,
the stuff that makes you ruminate on it
you'd have to you'd have to subtract in order for it to be just simple like
how to live your life stuff
self-help. Yeah.
This is totally reminding me. I'm I hadn't thought of this but like
I think about 10 years ago I wrote a thing
um
and it was like it was on Ecce Homo but it was like
the uh Nietzsche's 10 lessons on how to become what you are that was
I very intentionally did it in the framework of a self
of self-help.
You did that with um you were on the um
panel with Casey I think at RSA right? Yeah.
At RSA it was back in Austin I think it was I mean that was years ago
or San Antonio. Yeah. Yeah. Um and it it reminds me that and I had I mean it was
partly in like taking that and then twisting it right like it it so it reads like self and I was
really foregrounding like here are the rules right but one of those things where you follow the rules
and they don't they don't make sense and they don't add up and you can't just apply the rules
but they're not replicable but they're productive
yeah yeah absolutely and and I mean diagnostics is an action right? Yeah. It is not it is not a removal
from action so i'm just glad to remember that because that should that's part of the style book i need to
go back and grab that and put that in the book
well, the there are two there are two aphorisms i want to take us to 301 and then 306
largely to to nate's point about the sort of the merging of the theoretical or like diagnostic
orientation of this and the practical orientation of this and so 301 i'm not going to read the whole
thing. it's a bit long or i don't think i will um is the the delusion of the contemplative ones
and here basically it's like this this contemplative diagnostic interpretive
uh style of life it's it's not at a remove and that first sort of like we often talk about this
vis-a-vis Deleuze is that this is an action in the world and it's a creative interventive
productive like he uses it ends up using the like the the language of poetry um a poetic
production production of life around yes yes that you know this poem that we have invented is
constantly internalized drilled translated into flesh and reality indeed into the commonplace by the
so-called practical human beings our actors that it makes me think again of of Deleuze and his sort of
focus on you know this you know the most abstract you know theoretical you know um of all of us he was
the most of the full the most philosophical of all of us and yet he saw every this all of this
abstractness as immediately not applicable but directly and like analogically you know um um
action in the world the creation of different styles the creation of different kinds kinds of life
and you know then like there are a bunch of ways that he sort of like deals with these like half of
the aphorisms about both happiness and sadness are sort of then nuancings of that but you brought up
the stoics john so 306 is on the stoics and the epicureans right and he does another one of these
sort of like seemingly straightforward things um where it's like look the this the epicureans have
this you know incredibly contemplative life that um that or that that refines their possibilities
of pleasures and then increases their capacity for happiness but also their capacity and the
refinement for suffering and pain and you know what that's just better than the stoics who try to like
deaden all their senses to be able to survive tough times and that seems like it's the first you know
that just seems like you know hooray epicureanism go epicureanism right and then you know about
halfway through he's like stoicism may well be advisable for those with whom fate improvises and who live in
violent times and depend on the impulsive and changeable people and it's like well you know
suddenly stoic like epicureanism isn't simply the better option that stoicism like sometimes you need
to be able to inject some stoicism in one's life and in order to like you know prevent from system
overload or to be able to create to territorialize enough of the world to be able to make it you know
livable to make the world hang together just a little bit i love that i love the last line of
that one for this type and he's referring to the one not the sto you know not the stoic ones but for
this type it would be the loss of losses to be prived of their subtle irritability yeah
in exchange for a hard stoic skin with porcupine hedgehog skin, right? like it would be the loss of
losses to to you know the worst thing in a certain circumstance in other words there are times in
your life where you just want the the thick skin to let nothing affect you um and then there are times
and for him this is healthier times where you want irritation right you want something nagging at you
because that induces you to life i mean and so that's and that's where to me like that's what
i mean by the sort of practical side so it starts off as just saying like here's a way to live and
then what it ends up doing is being like there are just different ways to live right and they make a
difference right they make a significant difference and they are but they are born of different types
of conditions and different types of environments and settings and historical moments well and it makes me
think about all of this language of sort of like the um um the the danger and the value of overripeness
of decadence of you know and like it's like epicureanism is uh exactly the kind the the kind of strength
and danger of the opera overripeness of of decadence this incredible overwhelming subtlety of experience
that um that is signals that the not that you know things are like have like gone past their prime but
that you know the that the fruit has come to its full maturation and is now sort of like revealing or
is is expressing its you know its fullest sense that is going to by the way rot and give way to
something new but that doesn't make it bad it's just a different style of is a different style of life
so with with something like amor fati or love thy fate or whatever that actually translates to is that
a stoic thing or is that just Nietzsche's thing? Like, do you think that applies to both?
amor fati could certainly be read as a sort of sort of like stoic, um, resignation, just like
you know, whatever, like life i'm fated to is like ah, just like endure it, and so oftentimes
stoicism is configured as a sort of like enduring the experiences of life and building up a tolerance
to them so they don't knock you off your course, um, uh, Nietzsche seems to be just a little bit more
like it seems to be a little bit more subtle and an accepting of a certain kind of volatility which is
don't endure your fate, like love your fate, follow it, you know, in the it affirm it, and uh, yeah, like
let it like ride it out and follow its transformations, don't um, don't just like what ride it out as a wave
and let it pass, where Nietzsche's is more affirmative of sort of like um, almost indulge in in one's fate
and and delight in its sort of self in its self overcoming, you're not you're not partying yourself
against it and carrying it like the camel, you become the child and who takes it on and and um
right, i think that's dead on. i in fact had a conversation two weeks ago with a friend of mine
who was trying to link um sort of some Nietzschean thing uh to to aa as a kind of acceptance and i'm
like it's Nietzschean Nietzschean affirmation is not acceptance and we went back and forth on this a
couple of times and and it was acceptance is always acceptance of what is right which is to say
acceptance is always secondary and in relationship to being affirmation is the affirmation of becoming
like it it it it doesn't it doesn't begin from what is now there certainly are ways that you can read
nature like that right which is you can read the amor fati and the conventional understanding would
be like well shit happens and then you just kind of accept it or you just kind of love it for him or
or the next level would be you kind of you love it rather than just accept it but i think the next
level is the love of it is what makes it it yeah right so that it's not just it's not there is no
there there with without the relation of affirmation there's not such a thing as like an alcoholism to
accept or to right love or to whatever right there's that alcoholism is a style of life that's always
because because all of that will yeah that's right all all of those things will think and Deleuze makes
this point really explicitly in his book it's like if if affirmation as thought as the affirmation of
being it's not Nietzschean affirmation right like it's that that and again whatever i mean not that
there's anything wrong with the stoic version it's just here's a distinction with the stoic version for
me when i said how much it reminded me of the stoics it wasn't because of that it was more just because of the
like how to live inner of the thing right like this is like practical advice again that first of all
looks like advice reads and smells and feels like advice but seems to be actually more of a diagnosis
rather than advice and then it turns out that the diagnosis disposition is the advice right like i mean
yeah that that's the thing that's the twist that changes it but it just reads like Marcus Aurelius
yeah um, you know, a little bit to me
well it's just it's not prescriptive you know so even the like the affirmation is a project it's a
continual project and the character and shape of that affirmation develops or changes or shifts
you know through the different phases of it whereas a stoic acceptance that's a stable shape of acceptance
that's like that's one line of thinking or behavior that you can translate to every context whereas for
Nietzsche affirmation is context yeah it is you have to you know i mean that's that's right that's a good
way of saying i like that affirmation is uh is an affirmation is not something that you like you or i should
do it's just what we are right like and and there so for instance the epicurean and the stoic are both
affirmations of life just different types of life or different moments of the types of life right like that's to me
you know it's not like well there are epicureans and there are stoics it's that we're all some
you know concatenation of both of these things at different moments and different histories and
there's all kinds of you know content i mean as you're saying contextual reasons but those contextual
reasons are the things that are at stake so well that that line that you said that what we are is this
kind of affirmation it brings me to the one right after the stoics and the epicureans is like you know
these are just affirmations of life and you know they're like we would like to think that we reason
ourselves to a position and then our will adopts it and you know Nietzsche is always kind of switching
that and this is on in favor of criticisms something you formerly loved as a truth or probability now
Strikes you as an error, you cast it off and believe your reason has made it a victory. But maybe that error
was as necessary for you then when you are still another person. You are always another person as
are all your present truths, like a skin that concealed and covered many things you weren't allowed to see
yet it is your new life, not your reason, that has killed that opinion for you. You don't need it
anymore, and now it collapses and unreason crawls out of it into the light like a worm. When we criticize
we are not doing something arbitrary or impersonal. It is at least very often proof that there are living
active forces within us shedding skin. We negate and have to negate because something in us wants to live
and affirm itself, something we might yet we might not yet know or see this in favor of criticism
this, and by the way, that was the one because we talked about that last time, yeah, that was the one
where the Kaufmann, the Kaufmann footnote is. It might be interesting to compare this section with Hegel's
Phenomenology of Spirit. Yeah, yeah, hilarious little side note, but it's such a different kind of negation
though, right? Because it's this is the kind of negation of attack rather than a, like, uh, rather than a
negative space, right? Is that, you know, in order to make room for this new kind of life growing in
the old skin has to be shedded, you know? I don't negate my shedding skin, you know, like we, like, recycle
our skin, what, every 28 days, something like that. It's not like I'm philosophically or logically
negating that as an obliteration or setting up an opposition to it. It's just being shed off or cast
aside in as a byproduct of of of a new kind of life brimming underneath it. Well, the first thing the first
thing that he's doing that I think, and we would have to return to this sort of movement from sense and
pride the the first section of the Phenomenology of Sense Certainty, sense certainty to what's the next? I can't
remember. I mean, understanding, understand, understand perception, that's right, right, right, um, because
the first the first thing there is that um
negation is not or criticism is not something that's rational, right? It's not something that's
consciousness driven. It's not, it's, it's a symptom of a way of living, and so that's it. I mean, that's a
big conceptual move, right? So it's not, it's not a question of reason doing anything and finding
errors or whatever. It's a question of living needing certain types of beliefs and and so I mean as a
first move that strikes me as saying okay the the negation that's at stake here isn't consciousness
driven and I think that's Hegel like I think that you can you know that that's the interesting
version of Hegel, right? But it's not simply a question of consciousness that introduces negation
into uh into the movement of of things so in the world in the same way that like a niche and
niche and affirmation is not a simple acceptance. You could argue that a Hegelian negation is not a
conscious consciousness rejection. I mean that's what I took, you know? That's why negation enters the
picture before understanding does, right? Understanding is in fact a symptom of the movement of negation, but
doesn't there still have to be whether it's conscious or not still doesn't in order for the
engine to run there has to be a certain kind of recognition. There has to be a reification or like
an object. The recognition problem might be a hard one, like it doesn't object making out of a thing that
is being negated. It seems like what's happening here is that sort of like secondary, you know, byproducts
yeah, it's like it's not you don't need the reason to get rid of you don't need um you don't even need
to acknowledge the thing it's just sort of like you know this is just it's like more of like a noticing
that it's happening rather that's part of the engine. Yeah, and I thought like I thought this in
practical relationships with people where like I can think of a romantic relationship from my past
where uh during a certain during towards the end of the relationship like pretty much everything that
I said and did was met with just kind of irritability and and it's not that she was wrong
in being irritated by things that I said and did it just symptomatized a disposition which was like
everything I'm doing is a problem because I am fucking gross to you right? Like that's that's
that's just where we are right now and and I don't even blame you for that, right? Like it's not
it's not like what I could do is I could go through each thing and say well that's not really fair this
is not really fair or and I could make arguments as to uh why she's being too critical or something
like that but it's like look this is just the who you are right now is i as a force in your life
something that you just want away. Yeah, you know, and that happened so you know but it is is that is
it's like that that sense of the the the rational uh criticism of particular points is is an expression
of a disposition not uh the way you get to a disposition, right? And I think that's the major difference.
Right, no, uh, yeah, I mean, I think I, I think that it is, I think it it can be, but like, you know, and that's
but it's still one that I struggle with all the time in terms of the the function of the negative
for Nietzsche, right? Like, that you know because it's easy for that to simply fall back into
that sounds a lot like a strong reading of Hegel. Now, crucially, you're not going to get a sense of
progressivism from Nietzsche like that. To me is in other words, you're not getting better
by oh by shedding by shedding a skin different, you're getting different, and that's a, that's crucial
right? Like, you're just again, like, you have the sort of flat plane of different ways of living
you know, and and they and you move among them, and you know you don't you don't climb a ladder
right? You know, right, yeah, I wonder if the negative in Nietzsche it's just hard to frame these terms
within his lexicon, but like I wonder if it has more to do with like the unconscious dimension of your
situation in the sense that when like in this section when you're criticizing something that is an
unconscious symptom of your disposition, right, now you constitutively I think what he's suggesting is
that you're unaware of those symptoms in the moment, but you sort of just have to phase through them
or or get through those phases at some level. I think that you don't we most of us don't recognize
them as symptoms; we think of them as reasons. So we say we criticize something and we're like see
those are the reasons that i don't like that thing, you know, or or we try to come up with them as reasons
but the the the engine behind the criticism is not the reasons, you know, it's it's not like well the
reasons got her to this place where she realizes she didn't want to be in a relationship with me
like the yeah you know it's the other way around. I mean, you know, it's it's and and that's the sense
to me of like you really do have a um, you know, a materiality, a bodily disposition. Now again, it's not
going to be bodily in a simple material sense for reasons we'll talk about, but it's like that's a
that's a that's a pretty big move, right, from I mean in the end of the 19th century to say like hey
before Freud, right, to say something that's not your consciousness is the thing that is
determining your actions, frankly, right? Like, and and you think it's your reasons but your reasons are
just symptoms or excuses for your dispositions. Well a quick example is like and we've talked about this
is that my like lashing out at Barad or like whoever in the field was a version of it was a it was an
expression of my disposition. That's right, as much as a reflection of the actual object. That's right, so
and think of how it's changed. Yeah, exactly. Think of how your relationship to that change and think
of it was a hard process. I mean, it wasn't a you know it's even hard to call it a process because
like you know you go through various moments where you're like more like ah yeah but the empiricism
pisses me off and and then there are times we're like yeah i see the value of not criticizing her
empiricism, you know, it's it's that dispositional shift is is not just like I guess shedding a skin is
too clean of an analogy even because it implies like a fairly clear before and after, and it's like
it's a lot messier uh to and to and fro, right, and it wouldn't be a simple it wouldn't be a resolution
of the contradictions of my disposition to get to now, right, like you're saying it wouldn't be like
that it wouldn't be a diagonal right progression out of my superior more affirmative relationship to
Barad. It's like no it's just that you're capable of something else you'd have to add that you know not
just that you were always another person but you were always multiple other persons. That's that's
right, that's that's crucial
There's one passage that I I I wanted to point to, and this is a very small one, and this is one that
I I selected for uh to bring up with you guys because I could just so see how it gets misread
or so see how it gets read in a particular not misread gets read in a particular way in a conventional
particular way, and it's 281, um, and it's it's called knowing how to end, um, yeah, that's a good one. It's
very, it's very short, and I'll just read it: Masters of the first rank are revealed by the fact that in great
as well as small matters they know how to end perfectly whether it is a matter of ending a
melody or a thought or the fifth act of a tragedy or of an action uh or of an action of state the best of
the second rank always become restless as the end approaches and do not manage to and then this is the
part that interests me especially do not manage to slope into the sea in such profound and calm harmony
as for example the mountains of Portofino where the bay of Genoa ends its melody
Okay so we take the point masters of the first rank know how to end people who are not of the first
rank don't know how to end it's the quote-unquote metaphor that interests me right because there's an
easy way of reading that as a metaphor you know so because look all of the examples of ending that
he gives ending a melody ending a thought the fifth act of tribe these are the things that individual
subjects do right but then the example that he gives at the end is literally geological right
right and the easy way of reading that is well the geological thing is a metaphor
but i don't think it's a metaphor like i think when we're talking about this disposition is towards
living we're not just talking about humans we're talking about you know bays and lakes and rivers
yeah right like really i mean this is i mean but it was just one to me where it's like you know how
that that's going to get read it's going to get read as a um um an artistic poetic flourish to
metaphorize the circumstances when what he's really talking about is ending your book or ending a
conversation or ending an interaction that's what he's really talking about it's like i i don't think
he's really talking i think he's talking about geology just as much you know and so i mean that would be
sort of new materialist you know yeah read of this is that there is no structural difference between
mountains sloping into the sea and um an action of state or the the end of a podcast right um or or
whatever it is or the end of an interaction right there's no structural difference and it doesn't
matter that the actors are totally totally inhuman right in in the one case i mean is because
what you're sort of using as your baseline reference is the logic of ending the the the idea of thinking
the movement so i mean there is a thinking there right but that doesn't mean that it's a simply a
human thinking or a right or a human writing yeah i mean like the mountains of Portofino like we have
something to learn from the mountains of Portofino in as they as they uh trans uh trans translate into
the body into the bay of Genoa yeah right like there's something instructive not metaphorically
yeah well i mean yeah and two i mean i just i like how Genoa works for him and the way that you
know he's i mean i think this was in the last book but the way that he's sort of attending to the
like the craftsmanship and the art like the there's almost like you know the inhabitants of Genoa have
had a few centuries of sort of working of learning from the the mountains of Portofino and sort of so
living there is a perpetual pedagogy exactly right and that's where that that's going to be different
than the Stoics right like you know you're gonna say like this is the the the geology of your
circumstances are pedagogical right and and and ineluctably so you know so yeah it's like okay
you didn't you know you had the the misfortune to not live in Genoa and to be stuck in Columbia
South Carolina so you don't know how to end right because you never you were never trained in it you
not that there aren't other ways yeah yeah exactly we got a fucking swamp well it makes me think too
of the the bit on um prophets and the relationship to the to monkeys and when they know that sort of
like a lightning storm is approaching yeah it's like what we have we tend to mysticize you know the
prophets and think like they are they're just sort of like endowed with some kind of divine gift but
this is like there's a feeling or a sensibility to this and it's probably painful limiting right yeah
it's yeah it is it is limiting as well as it is in the exactly proportional to its the way in the ways
in which it's enabling yeah and so like you know this sort of like you know we learn from physiology we
were learned from geology and what it is to say to learn there isn't within the you know the language
of the understanding so much well that can certainly be part of it but as in the sort of the shaping the
habits of our disposition yeah i mean that's where you get a kind of i mean you can see how one would
get an existentialism out of that but i think that i mean i'd be more interested in a in a rethought
materialism out of that yeah it's almost like he's arguing that like the monkeys in that example
that they're like uh overtaken by rational man as opposed to an artist like in the sense that their
reaction to their environment is a version of this territorialization right what is it like it would
be a little bit dangerous to expand or contract too much you know right now because there's some
dangerous shit out there so i'm gonna hunker down i'm gonna get out of this rain cloud i'm going to
you know do the rational thing and and and i'm going to territorialize i know what that electrical
charge means and i've now sort of created a commanding sort of understanding of the world
around me and i'm going to respond you know i'm going to basically this is this is where you get
That, like, you know, for me, that's what what follows from the things that we've been saying for the last
10 minutes is this, in fact, the whole podcast? Like, this sort of diagnostic disposition is a fascination
with all modes of life, right? Like all different ways of living, not not even an implicit normative
even though it reads like that. I mean, come on, you can't read Nietzsche and not get the sense of like
here's the good guy, here's the bad guy, um, but it's always complicating that in ways, and what you get
what you get to is that there aren't right ways to live. There aren't better ways to live. They're just
a whole uh a panoply of different ways to live, um, that we're all immersed in our own sort of, you know,
constellation of those of those differences, of the amalgam of those differences, but they're all
fucking life is will to power and nothing else, like end of story, right?
Here, here are three eggs again. I I love the way that the contradictions are the nuance, like the
contradictions seem to nuance, right? Rather rather than create a sort of, you know, paradox, um, but they
they they create incredible amounts of subtlety. So here are three really short ones: 3 12 13 and 14
and see the ways in which these sort of intersect each other and force a kind of nuance and a subtlety
one upon the other. So 3 12 is my dog: I have named my pain and call it dog. It is just as fatal, faithful
uh, just as obtrusive and shameless and just as entertaining, just as clever as every other dog
and I can scold it and take my bad moods out on it the way others do with their dogs, servants, and wives.
3 13 is no image of torment: I want to follow Raphael's example and never paint another image
of torment. There are enough sublime things; one does not have to seek sublimity where it lives in
sisterhood with cruelty. Anyway, my ambition would would find no satisfaction if I wanted to make myself a
sublime torturer. 3 14 new domestic animals: I want my lion and eagle around so that I can always have
hints and forebodings to know how great or small my strength is: must I look down on them today and fear
them? And will the hour return when they look up at me in fear? Well, here we get sort of this like three
affecting um aphorisms on sort of pain, aggression, violence, fear, torment, cruelty, and yet they don't
neatly interlock with each other. They each one sort of shoots off in a direction and the other one
intersects and just nudges it like a few degrees. It it's if you if you sort of move back and forth
between them, it just what I like to think that happens is that the the trajectory of one just gets
nudged just a little bit by the other two. That well, you know, that that last line of you know 3 12, the
one on the dog, it's like, you know, that last line, um, I can scold it and take out my bad moods on it
like everyone else does on their dogs and their servants and their wives. What uh what it can be like
what a I dis on the way that of something maybe called toxic masculinity or masculinity
you know, you know, what I do, I just call that my pain. I I have my I have my pain, which is what I'm
actually responding to, and I give it the name dog, and I take my, you know, I take my anger out on it
and it's instructive, yeah. I I bet you mentioned that this is honestly one of my favorite parts
in all of Nietzsche is the footnote Kaufmann puts in there, um, this is attached to 3 11, so it's the
previous section which we don't have to get into, but it's it's a letter that he wrote to his friend
Peter Gost, um, in in 1880, and the quote is this: I've always loved this, like as a crucial a crucial
way uh aspect to understanding Nietzsche is to this day my whole philosophy totters after an hour's
sympathetic conversation with total strangers. It seems so foolish for me to wish to be right at the
price of love and not be able to communicate to communicate what one considers most valuable
least lest one destroy the sympathy, hence my tears right? Like that that sense of like I just love that
my whole philosophy like a a casual conversation with a total stranger in a bar, and like all of this
fucking falls apart you know, because it's like uh if i if i start saying some of this stuff we're not
going to be it's not we're not going to have a casual conversation among friends right? Like why can't i
just live in this rapport of of kind of comfort? Why do I have to say these the dog thing? Why do I have to
think the dog thoughts you know? It would just be so much better if I didn't, but I do. I mean, that's just
that's that's the mode of life that I inhabit. I I mean I love that it's just this it's such a sweet
comment, you know? Yeah yeah, my whole philosophy totters after a brief conversation with a total stranger
is that that has to be different from like uh just appeasing strangers or like um not liking
conflict right? That's not what he's exactly saying because I i'll do this thing where if somebody disagrees
with me politically i'll just start agreeing with them just so it's not uncomfortable you know I mean
I'm just like fuck it sure I like whatever you're saying that's I agree with that right you know
No, I don't think it's an avoidance of conflict. I think it's a it's an enjoyment of a rapport.
You know, it's like, oh, well, I'm not, you know, think of all those moments or at least I I this is me in
my life all those moments where I've like in my head I'm like I shouldn't say this
I shouldn't say this but like, you know, that thing that you're valuing right now is actually really
gross or is actually really a problem or is actually really sexist or is actually you know
and I'm like, oh my God, if I could have just shut up because they're not going to hear it they're not
going to learn it right it's not like so figuring out the you know the mode of infection has got to
be completely different than simply you know straightforwardly articulating your point
and making an argument it's like take them to Genoa and they'll learn yeah you know how to end well
we just can't talk about book four without talking about the eternal return what what section does he
where is it it's the second to last because the last one is insipid Zarathustra and that's where he goes
and writes that's where he goes and writes Zarathustra so it's the one right before that here I'll read
it out loud and we'll see where it goes 341 the heaviest weight what if some day or night a demon
were to steal into your lonely loneliest loneliness and say to you this life as you now live it and
have lived it you will have to live it once again and innumerable times again and there will be
nothing new in it but every pain and every joy and every thought and sigh and everything unspeakably
small or great in your life must return to you all in the same succession and sequence even the spider
in this moonlight between the trees and even this moment and I myself the eternal hourglass of
existence is turned over again and again and you with it speck of dust would you not throw yourself
down and gnash your teeth and curse the demon who spoke thus or have you once experienced a tremendous
moment when you would have answered him you are a god and never have I heard anything more divine
if this thought gained power over you as you are it would transform and possibly crush you the question
in each and everything do you want this again and innumerable times again would lie on your actions
as the heaviest weight or how well disposed would you have to become to yourself and to to and to life
to long for nothing more fervently than this ultimate eternal confirmation and seal
so this is I mean this is the one that's rendered as a thought experiment right like imagine the
the demon stealing in and basically posing this idea to you and does it fill you with terror or does it
fill you with delight and then most importantly how would this thought if it gets it becomes the earworm
and how does it sort of drive the way that you are acting you know the rest of your life living the rest of
your life if you know that you have to repeat everything that you're doing so and this is you know
certainly for Nietzsche this is what sent him off to write Zarathustra and this is the greatest lesson
I mean for the remainder of his career he's like this is the highest thought the thought of the eternal
eternal turn is the highest thought um it is it is there's there's nothing I mean for him he's just
like this is this is it you know um and there you know obviously there are multiple different
interpretations of um on the one hand and I've read a book that that claims that it's a cosmological
claim and there's evidence in Nietzsche's notebook that he really said like look given an eternity of a
universe things will repeat right like given eternity they and they will repeat infinitely like that's
just a that's a sheerly kind of cosmological claim about you know how the universe how the universe
operates there is the existential uh um version of that which is live as if right like live you know apply
this test to your actions right like I remember I remember when I first learned of the eternal return
it was in Jay Canter the guy who did crazy um or worked on crazy cat this is back in at Tufts in the um
late 80s early 90s and and he taught us the eternal return in in class and this idea that like
every action every action of yours is something that's going to be repeated infinite infinite
times and he taught it in that existential sense of use that thought as a test which is this thing
you're doing right now is this something that you can say I want to do this eternally and if it's and
if it's not then motherfucking do something else right you know I mean that again that's that existential
there's also like an ontological version which is more to Lose's right the eternal return of difference
um but yeah but uh um and there was a moment because I think a bunch of us in the class were
sitting there was like whoa you know we weren't nearly stoned enough or whatever to to really I mean
That's a big thought right? When you're 20 years old, like that's a big thought. And and he goes
You know, I've taught this, you know, for 10 straight years, and it continues to blow my mind that after I
say that all of you don't just get up and walk the fuck out of here because I cannot believe this is
where you want to be for eternity. And so again, he was thinking of it in that existential sense of like
apply it as a test and if it doesn't meet the criteria change your behavior, um, and then there
is of course this sort of, I mean, whether the eternal return is the eternal return of the same
or if what returns is difference, because there is no sameness in the Nietzschean ontology, and are we
making an ontological claim? And this, to Deleuze's version, is all that returns is difference, and it is
it is the test that life gives itself, not that we give life. We might be one manifest, you know
we might be one little part of life that does that sometimes, but this is like the bay going, you know
the mountains sloping down into the bay kind of quest, so I mean that's outlining schematically
without having prepared, like, the some of the different interpretations of this, this, in this case
in this instant instance of it, it sounds like a test, right? Like it, that's, it's, it reads to me like he's
saying, hey, have you, you know, would you, would would the thought of the eternal recurrence of this moment
terrify you, or or have you ever experienced a moment in your life that you'd be like this is
the greatest thing ever that I will get to this that I'm doing right now, I will get to do eternally
you know, um, and how does that change you to to to think of that as as the criteria by which you
move through the world? They don't seem to have to be mutually exclusive though either. Yeah, that's
what I was gonna say. No, they aren't. They aren't, uh, at all, and you could do various combinations of
those things, but they're just different, you know, slightly different orientation. The cosmological
question is different than, um, you know, certainly than the existential question, right? Right. Um, is
this just a kind of logical how the universe works? The cosmological one would seem to be a little bit
in conflict with the Deleuzian ontological one, at least in the sense that if it is everything were
to repeat it would be, it would have to still be different. I think that at least to me, um, that's the
question, the key distinction here. There are two. One is is is this subjective or is this the case in the
world? And the second question is is the eternal return, is it the eternal return of the same, or is
it not? Um, I think those those are the two questions. Um, and what does it mean to talk about it for Nietzsche?
What does it mean to talk about if we say the same, the eternal return of the same, what does that mean?
Right, given that what we were talking about in terms of affirmation as the affirmation of being
you know, is as not the affirmation of being, which is to say being doesn't simply pre-exist the act
of affirmation, uh, then then in that sense the eternal recurrence of the same isn't the same
it couldn't it couldn't be the self-identical because nothing would be self-identical to itself
that's what affirmation teaches you right? So and that's the Deleuze, I mean I'm just, that's the Deleuzian
reading of it and I know Nietzscheans that are like Deleuze's reading is Deleuze, it's not Nietzsche
which uh, that I mean it's it's you know, to to move it to the eternal return of difference
doesn't make sense within this particular aphorism. If you just read this particular
aphorism would sound exactly like the eternal return of the same, but if you read but nothing
about Nietzsche's ontology suggests that things exist to use his exact, you know, like that anything
is identical to itself, which he says over and over and over and over again. So you know, it just like
it would be what did he just have like this moment, eureka moment, and thinking but he forgot to think in
terms of you know, becoming instead of right? Or but given the fact that this is the highest thought for
the rest of his life it like it makes Deleuze's reading way more um, like it just seems like obviously
this is I think so too. I mean I think so too, but the real Nietzsche, I mean people who are hardcore
scholars and you know there's a spot because there was a spot he I mean Nietzsche writes this in in
his notebooks, like where he had the thought was on a walk and there was a rock and it was overlooking
whatever, I can't remember exactly where it was, but it's a it's a, like, a tourist destination now, like
go to the spot where Nietzsche had the thought of of the eternal return. I I've never been there
I guess maybe we should do that. That should be we should do a live podcast podcast road trip to
the spot of the eternal return. Is it in Italy? Is it in Turin or Clarino? I think it's in Turin. I think
it is. I think it's just outside of Turin, the mountains outside of Turin, I think so, northern
Italy I don't identify with them I'm a southern Italian sorry I can't go there okay you're not
allowed but just to think about it ontologically for a second because usually when we make the
cosmological argument, you know, it is that metaphysics of being that we're assuming yeah
but um and that and then the existential question is obviously hinged on that and then so you know that
you'd have to like change the um you'd have to change the the the logic of the the existential
question to plug it into the the um the ontological version of the the eternal return differences
which is say I'm not it's not that I am willing the same thing to return it's that what I am willing
is sort of my like the expression of difference or the affirmation of difference be the thing that
ripples and and causes the return of all difference right I mean that would be right like there would
be a different sense of eternity there that it's that this is different that's the more interesting
version is that yeah to me that's the more interesting version because one of the things that the
other variations don't do is they take eternity and temporality and and just sort of assign our usual
linear way of thinking to it but what you're saying up ends this idea of like there was the big bang and
then everything has sort of proceeded since then way of thinking of because time itself becomes its
stake in that thinking well yeah because especially if you think of a if you think of an ontology or
a cosmology of becoming right I mean like certainly there could be a big bang it just can't be
you know the the start right time doesn't work linearly like that and like the one thing that any sort
of notion of becoming would have to I mean be because of because of the because of the nothing there
aren't any laws right frankly there are there are no eternal laws there's no transcendent point of view
from which to view existence right because that's because we're assuming a flat plane of ontology
is that there are laws but there are there are imminently generated laws which means they're
malleable immutable which means that if part of what is at stake are the very nature of ways that with
the very nature in which things can relate to each other then now you've just like infinitely expanded
infinity yeah that's not like you know right yeah um it's not just that there are an infinite number
of things possible within our otherwise finite set of laws it's that laws are like this is an
autopoiesis of of natural law laws yeah are only ever the the authoring of new natural laws and that's
that's mind-boggling for me that's mind-boggling like that can induce a panic attack I was just gonna
say like that's the closest I've ever gotten to your sort of vertigo like you know like like going
out and like floating by Jupiter that's not so bad because I'm always within the bounds of the natural
universe but as soon as I get to this space it's like holy shit yeah the laws are are spanning off um
infinitely yeah as well well we'll think about all those things that Nietzsche's philosophy is not
right it's not a philosophy of a linear time or chronology or or whatever but all those things
that his ontology is not are symptoms of a certain disposition totally that he's trying to do something
other than so in that sense to me the eternal return would be an invitation to sort of cultivate
Deleuze's on like take on it so in in some sense for me the existential or ethical
interpretation the premise of that is the Deluzian ontological yeah yeah in the sense that it's like
given difference given relationality how do we not simply stabilize and reify that right how do we
how do we actually cultivate it I just had I think what might be my favorite thought um is just thinking
I know is is but is thinking the returnness of the action or returnness of like like a sense of the
returnness of the same but now think don't think of the same as an identity think of it in terms of
high sayity or kairos or or singularity and the the quality of of the affirmation is what infinitely
returns it never looks the same it's never recognizable as the same but because its differential force has now
marks everything everything because everything that's right the the the line is that is that return is
the being of becoming yeah that that the challenge of the thinking of the eternal return is not what
returns yeah it's to think return itself as the mode of being of becoming but not generically
returned idiosyncratic like like singular singular singular returns in each instance yeah yeah I mean
that's the line from the book you know return is that it's not a question of does the same return or
does difference return it is what is return and this is I think that was my blockage because I've read
that you know that's I think what that's that's um difference itself or is that I think that's the
difference itself chapters yeah um but I always heard return in that generic sense that's right
The standard sense of something returns yeah but but no no even just like it was like the pureness of
return i'm still thinking like return as a as a genre like returning meanings like yeah that that
even just the activity of returning but not thinking of like no there's an infinite set of returns of
kinds of yeah i mean i you know if you think of it in terms of turning instead of returning
right like and you just think of the return as being another turn yeah um yeah as opposed to just
like an angle on identity yeah it's heliotropism all the way down yeah yeah that was a major blockage
that was just sort of removed for me we unconstipated nathanael's thinking
you
We'll see you next time.